e io faccio l'intro a caso in giappone
perché mi dimentico di fare le in tra i
video
stiamo mangiando però sti cazzi fascia
che saluta e sapri oggi giochiamo un
gioco che piace un sacco stefano scala
player non batte i gravi buona visita ti
piace di installare installalo maledetto
strano intanto ai play off atto lei
giura metti il dato quel polmone di
fratello
se volete ammesso che lei sta in alto a
sinistra e dato che tu abbia ma lo
chiamano così deficiente
la partenza è buona allora vi spiego la
cosa avete fatto una partita no allora
ci sono due cecchini che dobbiamo
trovare se troviamo quelli abbiamo vinto
buono si chiama carc con la k e quello
che ho visto nel che ha messo nel video
si vede hai visto è adatto si chiama sks
quindi se trovi così in giro
allora vediamo dato arriva l'aereo e
andiamo subito buttarci io direi allora
ciccio nome lo si è buttato buttati
portati giocherà suicida
qui qui qui sei fermi alla città sotto
così almeno prendiamo tutte le mazzate
giuste adesso allora prima prima partita
ragazzi gli occhi riesce a morire per
prima e figli ma si è bellissimo ma tu
hai fatto un casino della madonna quali
casino tu non sai le tattiche
guarda che per molto meno ha lasciato
compagnia delle stesse ne so qualcosa di
storto ci sto quasi eterea e io so da ok
rivedo vivendole pietra l'edimes e di
fatto sia immerso in stranamente viene
come posizionamento aspetta che
ingaggiano un altro gruppo vediamo chi
la spunta che è successo niente milioni
da ciccio s'è girato anche una malata
ragazza è cagato software
io non mi ricordo come anche uno z1 però
qua se ammazzi una persona quella vaio
rianimazione quindi si no ma basta che
io seguo i video non ti preoccupare
ma lo sa bene ciò che era morto adesso
possiamo giocare seriamente dai
indossava lo sopporto ios all'indietro
dentro anche io stimo prisco l'ho visto
l'ho visto subito normale acqua dietro
dello zio gianfrate molti meriti non li
faccio il giro e tiene in ordine che
possono però che risultò due il
quartiere orti in tram chiudere entrambi
sono emilia costa sei forte fortissimo
ma ammazzati occhio è la dico sinistra
io per te che sia facile per te vi
faccio il giro di ammazzo sono dietro le
tele occupati dai preoccupati di romania
ma sento bene
grande azione nell'area di grande
giuseppe grazie simone è bravo perché io
ho chiamato subito il primo capito
quindi non è che abbiamo invitato per
questo allora è morto solo gioca e
quindi mi sono sacrificato della squadra
allora io avevano un bottoni mirini e
non gliel'ho dato io ho preso qualcosa
se comunque in tutto questo siamo a noi
siamo nella zona anche matteo 8 20 volte
mai indicato ascolto allora siamo nella
zona sicura quindi alla fine il fatto di
joker di buttarsi questa è stato un bene
che per lui però sta cosa
ma c'è stato ci sta sempre uno che si
sacrifica a pasqua è la macchina eccola
quindi dire che possiamo farci avete un
caschetto figo è casomai lesbico sali è
ovvio ci che quando poi scendere dalla
macchina in corsa e ti fai male boia di
aspettare che la macchina si fermino mi
chiama detto l'ho detto che domani al
parco due tutto il contrario dell'ance
non lo so lo so lo so perfettamente
beccato prendi la mattina o fare pechino
miqua per gioco e per ciò che lo
facciamo fini cinieri ragazzo stava
quasi per gioco
lo facciamo per gioia dove sta pietro
insomma va fatto una pietra commemoriamo
ci lavoriamo come fanno esplodere 6
milioni di iscritti insieme guardate
aspetta faccio il cazzo che c'è come non
c'è dice no c'erano i 249 dai non è male
viene entra cittadini [ __ ] e
ringraziano trovare una guida tufani
strafavorito ripiega sta roba
ma no
stai fermo alla famiglia
[Musica]
occhio che arriverà gente da ovunque noi
siamo nel mezzo della merda ma
resisteremo o ancora in carta più per 4
è il cecchino ma ammazzati ma tua
sorella
ma che cazzo è spiegato allora vediamo
un po arriveranno tutti ma sai cosa vuol
dire tu avremo il culo l'intendo proprio
tutti la tua to my forse è poco di tutti
quanti 42 live quindi dovremo spara un
bel po siete pronti a scaricare più
amore bravo ciò che potrà o gioca allora
vedi adesso si sta restringendo il
cerchio blu appena tocca bollo bianco si
vede subito dove si restringe ancora se
si restringe ancora su di noi siamo
messi da dio però non si restringerà più
senza uno scontro a fuoco sicuro non ce
l'abbiamo intercooler non ci fosse
perché culo c'è una cosa che cioè il
lancio del paracadute macchinari 75
arriva penisola
niente ci doveva spostare è pronto a
morire ci pare tornato macchina macchina
dritto e dove sto curando io albero
dietro l'albero praticamente non dietro
o molto dietro la spiaggia o che l'ho
visto l'ho visto visto andiamo la
macchina qui però il mito non troppo
positivo mi raccomando e l'ultimo sì
tipico che saranno tutti gli etero di
noi che sono andati sei ragazze muoio
ricordatevi di me come mais opportuni ma
deve pure per cui si chiede comunque per
noi
tantissimo addio lo re addio cosi che
dietro aiuto io anche dietro le gare lo
so che non sono neanche abbiamo anche
una ragazzi ok
dobbiamo dare in secca
dunque vicino loro mamma si porti mostra
morti sono morti sono morti scapoli
scoprire così sicuro in avanti ciccio
antigori remix remix premi una volta xc
a me sem e sputa lo sopporto datevi per
te dietro un albero per the arab unità
di l'ombra io ti aspetto aspetto
aspettati la conta attenzione
dovreste muovervi col gas ecco tu che è
il cecchino sei quello che deve faticare
a posto perché è la zona per possiamo
uscire ancora gcc e ancora da insafe ai
parlano tutti i pc e guarda ecco è morto
in tre tantissimi no no no a prenderla
presenti e non vorrei dire aspetti ma
stai graham tutto vedrete minore grande
gioia
stiamo a fare un'altra donna i cerchi li
buttiamo c quando si butta lui e al
giallo 32
no se successo di chiusura non ma
veramente a me ne sono andato dai 21
andavo delle procure ha poi io sto
andando ad appoggiarmi madonna che
avevate ancora la vedo a bola purtroppo
e red bull un funzionano veramente
dentro la mia casa e io te lo spara le
commesse che appesti è un cecchino come
era il dott
il tutto con terapie ma non ci credo
l'ho ammazzato 1 a volare io non è
massimo che c'è uno zaino se poi le
posso da quello assai nate in faccia
forte c'è anche un tipo che serve una
cosa è un televisore vi serve
sì grazie per quattro il cecchino regalo
insomma chiuso né alcun maggio
bravo donna vera guida è bravo è bravo
investiti da voi
attualmente e mista 66 tornare dove io
sono passato renzo dobbiamo andare là
per forza di andar via è un isoletta
questa spetta vediamo siamo ancora salvi
ci è andata bene però dobbiamo andare
qui perché si restringerà più o meno qua
la zona finale vi ho sentito una barca
non vorrei di fregate e infatti a farli
fuori o tocca che loro non è morto ma
non è morto
uno è morto è morto solo uno un altro
non è morto mentre era in mezzo alla
quale sono legato più cazzo mi sono
sfuggiti che non uno stato un babbo di
nicchia ciò le scommesse sul mercato che
figata
non è mai successo no non c'è qualcosa
che non va lega aiuto e chaz m lanciano
fumogeni ma il fumo c'è un nemico lo
attaccano qualcuno mi lasciano fumo ci
riguarda a roma resta pizza è mangiato i
fagioli prima ha lanciato pesanti aia di
st ma fatemi vedere dove sto stronzo e
l'impegno della famiglia ma dove non li
vedo ecco lì dove ho visto lo butto giù
io sono a 345 by hamann colpi network
questa nota la china
reja prendiamo prendi a venire a
prendere io quando volpedo mortacci loro
schermati qua dietro ma è però dietro
l'albero timore ma penso ma poi fa guida
mai mi fraterno però sono un video che
siamo morti
non esitate salva dietro l'albero mio
fermati al polissi ma qui con punti 6
riesce a rimanere seri fermati poi avrei
parti subito weimar è cinico subito
subito subito via previste che va il
turbo
io non è vista la gente molto presto e
comunque la fede medici vero fermati si
può fermati e giù per giulia trama
chiede trattino temi chiesa dietro ho
detto e ve ne vedevo decidente morta
bravo chi è che ha colpito web un
rarissimo ciccio il fatto che possono
fare perché ciò femminili bene io sono
note innamori morto quindi sto usando il
big match a pescia ecco l'ultimo porca
meno ragazzo ragazzi dentro il gas è
sinistra mattina davanti lavori ma è il
furbo turbo il primo turno corri corri
corri corri fai vai vai con la jolie ha
detto la jolie morente lascia lo faccio
lo lascerò paesi ma
marina guida dentro il gas dentro gaza
letta e questo io mi sono salvato per
inerzia tra l'altro morti tutti presto
le famosissime parole famose
io l'ho vista morì degente giusto voglio
cazzo sei un veggente ma i ragazzi nel
frattempo che avete visto il video a
tutti no non è vero
sono passati dieci minuti e mi piace
stefano e gli è piaciuto adesso solo si
caricano di queste partite non romperle
palle che non lo sai
vabbè amato tromba tenerezza questa cosa
non so perché mi è piaciuto come ti
piace anche brescia ci ha chiesto ma
come si chiede noi ci vediamo non
possiamo invitare casa
[Musica]